هم بالالاف هم بالالاف هم منهم من ياتي
الى هنا ثم بعد ذلك يخرج الى الخيام او هو
بالاساس كما نشاهد الان هو
يعد الى الطعن نشاهد كيف ان هذا المتطوع
يقدم له المشروب يعتقد ان هذه هي
اعتقد ان هذه هي الفطور
خلينا نشوف ابا احمد سوري شو هذا شوربه
هيدي الشوربه ايضا هؤلاء المتطوعين عند مع
ساعات الصباح هذا الخبز بالاضافه ايضا الى
هذه الصوره من المقلب الاخر يعني كيف هي
مطعم وكيف هي
بالوقت ذاته محل للمنامه نشاهد هذه الصوره
لا اريد ان ان اعمل مشكله ولكن يبدو ان
هذه هذا الشخص متطوع الحم المدنيه مكتوب
على ظهر هذه الحمايه المدنيه من اي خليني
اذهب من اي مدينه حضرتك ونعم تونس انت
تونسي قدمت من كم يوم الى المدينه
اليوم الثالث انتم فريق فريق بحث وانقاذ
تبع الحمايه المدنيه التونسيه تم
انت على العربيه مباشره
كم هو الفريق فريق متكون 41 عنصر يتكون
معهم اربع انياب ومعدات تقنيه في البحث
والانقاذ من تحت الانقاذ
كم الاعداد التي
استطعتم ان تنقذوها من تحت الارقام ان كان
احياء حاليا اول ما وصلنا كنا بمعاينه
اماكن المضره تحديد الاولويات حسب سرعه
المحليه والانطلاق في عمليه البحث
والانقاذ واخراج المصابين تم تحديد بمناطق
معناها في انهيار كامل
مع تاكيد وجود ضحايا تحتها قمنا البرح عمل
في اول مبنى توصلني الى خارج اربعه موته
رحمهم الله والعمل
الاصطناعي فالتوقيت الحصر فيه
اشكرك واستريحني عذرا انني ايقظتك وانت
تاخذ القصه من ابو خالد حضرتك قلت لي
انتقل يا ابو خالد هل بالامكان سؤال سؤال
هذا العنصر من الانقاذ ماذا عن الامال هل
من الممكن قبل ان يذهب
نعم يسالني يسالني بعد مرور هذه الايام في
دبي هل نعم نعم هل هنالك من امان للحصول
للعثور على احياء تحت الانقاض الاحيان
موجودين في عوامل طبيعيه اخرى تؤثر بخلاف
الانهيار فهو بروت الطقس ثم الجوافه العطش
فالحاله الصحيه بتاع المصاب فلنعيد
الاصابه يتحصل عليها في
الموجود والعمل موجود وربي سبحانه وتعالى
انا سخرنا واحنا حاضرين نحاول نساعد
العباد هذول ان شاء الله نحن نعمل
البحث تدل في مؤشرات في ان شاء الله نكون
في المستوى وان شاء الله
في عمق اعداد بالنسبه للسوريين في المدينه
عدد الضحايا او عدد الذين تحت الاوقات
تقريبا المعروفين بالخمسين موجودين اليوم
تحت الانقراض يعني الفرق التونسيه جورجيه
كلها من من كان عندكم من الفرق المتخصصه
اتى الى حيكم جورجيا
الساعه تقريبا
بالتاسعه اخرج الاطفال من تحت الالقاب
احياء
شهداء شهداء ماذا تفعل انت الان هنا في
هذا يعني
لاي مكان يعني
برايك برايك على الارض
التقديمات هي جيده حتى الساعه الناس كلها
مدنيه يعني
لمساعده القرى الابيض وصلت قبل ما توصل
الدول
يعني صارت الناس حتى اللي موجودين هون
يعني اي مساعدات الناس كلها
برايك انه بالنسبه للطعم للشرب أمن كل
الناس يعني
اي واحد محتاج كل الناس عم تقدم المساعده
نعم